let's go to the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
our first caller is going to be from the
7 7 8 area code and callers you'll be
able to hear all the callers so please
pay attention to if I say your area code
because you won't be able to tell that
I've put you on because you'll be able
to hear the entire segment the new thing
that we're doing this is the new thing
but you got to pay close attention so 7
7 8 do you know who that is and are you
with us hi David
yes just wanted to commend you on the
interview you did with Colin Moriarty
and I was wondering what your thoughts
on him were maybe anything changed
before and after learning no I pretty
much had a good sense of who he was and
you know that I think the overwhelming
reaction from the audience and I don't
want to put Colin in a box per se but
like the most I would say the most the
mode and mean of all of the comments
that I received were friendly
conversation it was a conservative that
you could speak to reasonably but he
didn't have any particularly interesting
or unique insights he seemed sort of
like yeah he's got some positions he's
pretty friendly about them but no real
mind-blowing perspectives or anything
like that but I noticed was when he was
taking a position that was opposite to
the libertarian approach yeah he would
be open about that I mean you said that
he has to put his libertarian beliefs
aside for that one yeah he'd say on this
I'm a libertarian on that I'm not what
did you think of the interview more
specifically oh well I appreciated that
it was really civil tell me reason why I
I guess followed him really was before I
even got into American politics and not
American by the way was watching Bill
Maher Real Time with Bill Maher and when
I whenever he talked about conservatives
Republicans it was always though they're
super religious they're super
close-minded and I found this guy on the
internet who had a serious call to
conversation with Colin and he was
really pretty reasonable he was willing
to you know talk to the Liberals and
maybe meet somewhere in the middle so
they go and that's not picture that I
always had in my head yeah
all right very good oh she ate it
enjoyed talking to Colin and you know
maybe we'll have him back someday yeah I
just want ask question do you know who
roaming millennial is nope no idea okay
well she's another upcoming youtuber
conservatives and she just did a video
on why she doesn't really think the UN
is very efficient and why she's not a
fan yeah I was just wondering to you
yeah alright well alright sounds like an
exciting topic yeah I'll look at that
thanks for the call very much appreciate
it